let's bring in retired air vice marshal
sean bell who is
down at the sky straight at sk in sky
news center for us uh and sean just just
talk through the significance of what's
happened in the last 48 hours or so
good afternoon jane yes a quick update
of across the region um let's start with
the north the spectacular successes that
the ukrainian forces have had across to
the north jester east of of kharkiv um
the russians have built some new
defensive lines now svetova and east of
the uh um
oscarville river the key location really
is it's really important because the
resupply lines for russia into the
donbass region here but also
strategically this is all part of
luhansk region and russians will not
want to give that region up given its
importance it's also worth remembering
the russians soldiers their position is
really fragile at the moment they've
been badly mauled by the ukrainians and
the ukrainian tales are up if we move
down to hessen down to the south west
there very different approach by the
ukrainians here um much more in circle
and uh and uh restrict um the they're
looking to literally cut off the forces
from their russian resupply across the
dinitro river and also isolate the
forces as we go um the fighting has been
going on around houston but it's really
important to notice that that fighting
is not a precursor to any uh a massive
offensive into helsing that would be
really damaging for the ukrainian forces
be very very difficult to do so much
more likely just to squeeze and finally
we move across the donbass as an
opportunity to uh what's happening there
quite a surprise in the donbass because
the russians have been
continuing offensive operations
particularly around donetsk itself um
unusual because normally when they're
under attack in so many other areas you
use any spare capacity to plug the gaps
um so it looks very unlikely this
russian offensive will take any
realistic ground and it's been described
as a robotic effort by some quarters if
we zoom out again though and look some
of the commentators have been talking
about um what putin's options are with
international support potentially waning
a bit he keeps referring to this special
military operation clearly doesn't want
to escalate it to a war that could be a
sign of if his forces can take the
remaining area of the donbass here then
he would be able to declare success and
potentially start negotiations from a
zelinski perspective though their morale
is on the up they've taken on russia on
the battlefield and they have prevailed
using a mixture of surprise uh and
ingenuity and uh that they will be
wanting to uh capitalize on that again
the challenge is where would you
actually
mount your next attack if you were to
create some real problems all military
forces hold forces in reserve generally
they are there to plug gaps if your
enemy mounts an attack but you could use
those in the offense and they could use
those anywhere along this land bridge
down to crimea from uh from the donbass
and that could create some really
interesting challenges uh for president
putin but zalenski's strategic ambitions
haven't changed russians all out of
ukraine and therefore despite the fact
that there's been a marked shift in uh
in in in the success over the last few
weeks the reality is there's been
nothing happen decisive and we're in for
a long hold long hard winter